hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the sony xperia z5 premium so this is
one of sony's trio of new android
smartphones for this year and it's about
what you'd expect from them so a much
improved 23 megapixel camera on the back
a snapdragon 810 chip adreno 430 gpu and
three gigabytes of ram inside alongside
a beefy 3400 milliamp hour battery and
all in a metal body that's ip68 water
resistant and flat with its clean
understated design very sony so aside
from the unbelievably awkward placement
of the volume button what makes this
phone unique what's so premium about the
sony xperia z5 premium well it's rocking
a 5.5 inch 4k ips display on the front
that rings in at an insane pixel density
of
806 pixels per inch so you got to know
that 4k is another word for uhd
resolution which is 3840 by 2160 which
is exactly four times 1080p that's a lot
of pixels and this is the world's first
4k smartphone or to be a little bit more
precise the world's first smartphone
with a 4k display so the thing about it
and you might have actually heard about
this is that it really renders pretty
much everything at a four to one ratio
so
1920x1080 if you take a screenshot of
the home screen it'll tell you it's 1920
by 1080. and most apps that read the
phone's resolution will tell you it's
1080p because it's rendering everything
at that 1080p for regular use and this
saves battery and graphics strain on the
gpu
but in certain apps
it does render in full 4k specifically
in apps where you're viewing high
resolution content like in your gallery
when you're looking at super high-res
images or watching 4k video and that's
where it really shines the weird thing
is you can actually see it snap into 4k
mode it takes a few seconds once you
open the content but then once you see
it
it snaps on and when it does it sort of
unlocks a bunch of detail and a bunch of
textures and things that appear that you
couldn't see before you can tell more on
certain images than others but this one
for example
boom it just really pops when it turns
on when it makes that switch so the
golden question here is can you actually
tell the difference in image quality
between 4k mode on the xperia z5 premium
and another really high-end smartphone
display so to test it out first we'll go
at an arm's length so this is a z5
premium snapped into 4k mode at an arm's
length so go ahead and make sure you're
watching in 4k and get a good look
and then this is the nexus 6p so a
high-end quad hd amoled display showing
the exact same image here's another of
the xperia z5 premium pause it if you
need to and then here's the nexus 6p now
you can only tell so much through
youtube but it's pretty much impossible
to see the difference between these two
at an arm's length especially when you
hold them side by side you would think
you'd see the difference but you kind of
don't because the human eye can only
resolve so much detail at that distance
so that's kind of the point of these
high resolution displays you may
remember my explained video way back
about retina displays pretty much every
smartphone has a retina display these
days where the pixels are too small to
see them from an arm's length so next i
did an up close test here's xperia z5
right up close
and then here is that same picture on
nexus 6p
again xperia z5 right up close
and nexus 6p curiously even from a
pretty close up distance the difference
is just barely noticeable and that's
when you're really pixel peeping at a
closer than normal distance to your
phone which hey some people do but i
guess that's not really considered
normal use then finally i broke out the
macro lens which is basically a
microscope and tried it again
and now you'll really start to see some
differences so this time i'll do nexus
6p first and keep an eye here on the
detail in the shutters on the windows
and on the rooftops and all those
shingles
now this is xperia z5 there it is you
get much more detail these thinner
smaller lines smaller pixels here's
nexus 6p again and i'm mainly looking
here at the blades of grass up front
and here's xperia z5 it separates the
grass much better thanks to all those
pixels and then here's another one check
out the mountains on nexus 6p which by
the way is a great display it's one of
the best out there which is why i'm
using it for the comparison look at the
trees on the mountain up on the left and
the windows on the building
then boom xperia z5 all the windows and
all the trees really impressive stuff
here's the closest i could get to the
panel with a macro lens on the nexus 6p
you can actually see the red green and
blue sub pixels here and the matrix used
to make the quad hd grid and then here's
the xperia z5 premium which honestly has
a pretty unusual subpixel matrix looking
like a bit of a zigzag pattern which you
would think would hurt straight lines
and more a lot but the subpixels are way
too small for the naked eye to notice
that they're crazy small and it took a
super macro shot to really appreciate
this difference so at the end of the day
if you go out and buy this phone will
you actually be able to see the
difference between it and another
high-end smartphone display
no you probably won't like we said it's
rendering most of the ui elements and
graphics and games and apps at 1080p and
that's good because that means it's
saving a little bit of battery life a
little bit of graphics power you're not
dropping any frames trying to push all
those pixels with huge animations
but when it actually does click into 4k
mode it takes a second and there's a
very small observable difference at a
very close distance from your face and
this kind of shines light on the fact
that at this level resolution isn't
everything in fact the bigger
differences you'll see between this
display and others will be in viewing
angles and contrast ratios and color
temperatures and accuracy and brightness
so the fact that we have a smartphone
with a 4k screen is pretty awesome it's
an engineering feat and it's something
we kind of predicted a little while ago
you're going to see 4k phones sooner or
later and probably a year or two we're
going to be having 4k displays in our
pockets as insane as that sounds but
yeah that being said this is the first
one and in the way i phrased at the
beginning of the video this is a
smartphone with a 4k display but it's
not really a 4k smartphone i think we'll
see the first real full-time true 4k
smartphones next year and in the
following year after that but right now
this is the first one with a panel of
its kind it's awesome to look at
sometimes but i wouldn't buy it just for
the screen so there you go bragging
rights for sony we're just not quite
there yet and display aside this is
actually a really nice phone either way
thank you for watching this video hope
you enjoyed hope you learned something
and if you want to share it feel free to
do that too again thanks for watching
and i'll talk to you guys in the next
one
peace